have you yourself having been involved  in this closely at that time do you have  an opinion what happened yes I have an  opinion but what do you think exactly  what militare said is they shot him with  a high-powered rifle and they had a  patsy all set up who was silly all round  saw how deeply believe that and I hate  to say it that this thing assassination  of the president went to the highest  position in our government that there  was a coup to take him out of power  because not only was he heard two  southerners but him one to pull out a  Vietnam in the morning to go back to the  standard as so far as a monetary system  was concerned all of these things would  have severely crippled the money  Powell's here in the United States so he  had to be eliminated